荒井島の中に、なんかあの、薄皮芯とかが屋根の死につくと、すごい大変だって、この間テレビでやってた。
匂いだね。
屋根の色。
でも、薄皮芯は駆除できないんですかね。
荒井島は害虫なんで、駆除。
ああ、そうなんだろうね。薄皮芯はなんか悪いそう。
どうしたんですか?今、もう駆除されたんですか?
いや、死によって、業者が来てくれて、庭に網を設置してくれたんです。
捕獲する網を、業者がこう、リンゴの中にコロンと入れて、1週間置いといて、引っかかったら連絡くださいって。
もうね、網を置いたらもう来ないんですけど、分かって。
結構賢いの。
でも、来なくなったんだろうね。
まあ、それで、実際来なくなったね。
よかったですよね、それは。
何回も来てたのに。
うちに、木鉢って庭でね、実家から持って、これぐらいの木鉢が来て、そこにメダカを買ってたんですよ。
かわいい。
水分増えて、もう20匹ぐらいいたんですよ。自分で売った時と。
水中の花とか置いて。
へぇー。
それがね、ある時からメダカがいなくなって、あれー?おかしいなーって。
最後1匹になって、これはおかしいって、死体もないんですよ。
えぇー。
で、唯一の1匹を大事にしてたな。
その最後の1匹も亡くなって、荒い熊が来て、
とはって、うんうんうん。
え、お家の中に庭ですね。庭か。
あ~。
え~。
でも、あんなちっちゃい、こんなのをね、すごく器用、いや、コインとかこんな大きいんだったら、見つかめると思う。
こんなちっちゃいメダカ、全部なくなるぐらい。だから結構器用で。
へぇー。
賢い。
で、メダカ全部食べ尽くした、もう来ない。
へぇー。
そうなんだ。
そういうと、メダカでもいらっしゃったり、リ、リキの、あれ、ほら、なんだっけ、あんこうじゃなくて、なんだっけ、
ポル、ポルファベリティ。
あれあれ、ほら、ナマズ。
あぁ、あ~。
ナマズが最後、その水槽から出ちゃった。
あぁ、かわいそうだったね。
ナマズ、勝ってた。
勝ってた。
ナマズって、カイツだったのよね。
うん、いや、最初ナマズだってわかってなかった。
そうなんだろう。
あ、そうなんだろう。
何だと思ったの?
なんか、サメ、サメみたいな、小さいサメでかっこいいなと思った。
小さいかな。
みんな形してたよ。
小さいサメだと思ったら、ナマズって大きくなるでしょ。
うん、そうなんだ。
大きくなってますよね。だから、このくらいの水槽に勝ってと、それで入らなくなるって、楽しみにしてたんだよね。
そうだっけ。